whoa before we get started I want to go
over the four sponsors for this episode
who make all this possible
they're fantastic so go show them some
love the first is the best URL in the
industry crypto comm their crypto
platform with one goal driving mass
adoption that's why we're all here right
to get every human on earth a digital
wallet and to get them using digital
currencies crypto comms helping people
do that through buying earning lending
and a new card payment everything you
could want is at crypto calm they've
been longtime supporters of
off-the-chain and recently announced a
new exchange so go help them out
download their app from the App Store or
visit crypto comm and tell them pom sent
you there's nothing better in the world
than a company helping to drive global
adoption of this new technology another
part of global adoption is making sure
that we secure the various block chains
with computing power coin mine has built
the best consumer experience in mining
hands-down no competition if you want to
help secure the blockchain and get
started in mining you can go to coin
mine comm slash pop order a coin mine
it'll arrive at your door
and you simply take it out of the box
plug it in and connect to your Wi-Fi
you'll be mining your favorite crypto in
five minutes or less it is honestly
magical I have one running right now
here in the office and it's super quiet
it's got no heat and every person that
comes in the office asks what is that
every single person asks it's a coin
mine the best part to me is that the
coin mine comes with a mobile app that's
super slick and the company continues to
push over-the-air updates to the device
that add functionality ad tokens that
can be mine or increase the efficiency
of the device similar to how Tesla does
car software updates over the air
coin mines sending these passively to
thousands of coin mines around the world
on a periodic basis pretty damn cool
when far booed and the team pitched me
on the idea of an Xbox or Playstation
like box that could mine cryptocurrency
in your home I was immediately sold I
invested in the business have a device
personally and keep telling people to go
to coin mine comm / pump so they can
save a lot of time if they want to get
started mining today in coin mine has a
partnership with our third sponsor for
this episode block 5 block 5 is one of
my favorite companies in crypto because
they allow users to deposit their assets
in a deposit account and immediately
start earning interest think about it if
you keep your digital assets on an
exchange or in cold storage you aren't
benefiting from any yield on the
asset with block fie they allow you to
deposit crypto and then get paid
interest on a monthly basis in crypto
deposit Bitcoin and want to get your
interest payment in eath you can do it
deposit Bitcoin and want to get your
interest payment in Bitcoin you can do
it the rates have block fire are
currently some of the best in the
industry
you can earn six percent interest on
Bitcoin and you can earn up to eight
point six percent 8py on G USD deposits
I'm an investor in the company and think
block fights building really important
and compelling infrastructure so go
check them out at block fire comm slash
pump again this block five comm slash
pump and that brings us to the last
advertiser of the episode eToro these
guys have absolutely crushed it over the
years their founder yoni was one of the
original Bitcoin OGIS that has been
ahead of almost every trend in crypto he
built eToro to help people buy sell and
trade crypto currencies but he added a
few twists social trading copy trading
and virtual trading accounts social
trading is a feature where every asset
available on the platform has its own
separate social feed where people talk
about the asset share trading ideas and
analysis and even include various charts
or graphs virtual trading accounts is
targeted at beginners if you're just
starting out and want to try trading
with play money eToro will give you a
virtual account with $100,000 in it to
test learn and get comfortable and so
then that brings us to copy trading
which is by far the coolest feature this
allows you as a user to select any other
users portfolio to copy if you see
someone on the platform you like you can
set your account to mimic their trades
they buy Bitcoin with 5% of their
portfolio your portfolio buys 5% Bitcoin
they sell 50% of their ether position
your portfolio does the same thing
automatically copy trading is awesome so
go join the 10 plus million other
traders on eToro and start trading all
the most popular cryptocurrencies today
they're one of the largest companies in
the space and you can get started by
going to e Toro comm again that is eToro
comm where the entire team is ready to
get you started in just a few clicks and
don't forget go subscribe to the
off-the-chain daily newsletter you can
go to off-the-chain sub stack comm I
write a letter of news analysis and
opinion every morning that goes out to
more than 40000 investors see you there
what's up everyone this is Anthony popli
I know most of you know me as pomp
you're listening to off-the-chain simply
the best podcasting crypto let's kick
this thing off
Chris gore manages the finances of
various wealthy families and advises on
their investment portfolios he has also
been incredibly helpful to me in
retirement planning and was the
individual who originally introduced me
to Marc usko and Morgan Creek so I
wanted him to come on the podcast and
share his insights in this conversation
we discussed portfolio construction the
macro economy the psychology of money
and investments and how Bitcoin is
currently perceived by his type of
client I really enjoyed this
conversation and I hope you do as well
Anthony pomp leon o is a partner at
Morgan Creek digital all opinions
expressed by pomp or his guests on this
podcast are solely their opinions and do
not reflect the opinions of mode Creek
digital or Morgan Creek Capital
Management you should not treat any
opinion expressed by pomp as a specific
inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only
alright guys bang bang I'm sitting here
with Chris we got a whole bunch of stuff
to cover it's gonna be a really special
episode I think because we're gonna get
the perspective of a financial adviser
both in the traditional world but also
how clients currently are thinking about
Bitcoin and crypto currencies so thanks
so much for coming to do this no problem
thanks for having me no pressure bro no
pressure
alright let's uh let's get into your
background we know each other for a long
time but go ahead and tell everyone kind
of what we did before the financial
advising works yeah I graduated college
and realized no one's going to trust
twenty-something year old kid with all
their money so I figured need to go
leverage the big brand names that were
out there see if I couldn't use them to
get my foot in the door speak with
wealthy clients talk about their
financial planning went to a five
trillion dollar asset manager use their
brand name to a bunch of doors was
working on retirement plans and
financial investment portfolios for
companies like Oracle time where cable
big fortune 500 companies like IBM it's
fun while lasted but uh had to move on
so I what do you exactly do when you're
doing like retirement planning for big
organizations like that
well like I get that people need to help
I'm like what exactly does that work
entail yeah everyone really thinks that
they're going to try to identify this
number out in the distance where it's if
I can get two to three million dollars I
can retire but just like you and I were
talking about a minute ago you think
about it backwards so there's this
really interesting story about Tiger
Woods when he will go into the golf
course he'll actually start the 18th
hole and walk backwards so we can try to
help clients identify everything that
they're going to need in retirement you
know how much money they're gonna spend
doing the in complaining first we can
walk that back to a realistic number on
hey you can save XYZ or you can get your
investment portfolio to this number you
shouldn't have any worry about being
able to retire successfully yeah and so
like what is the average number would
you say most clients you do a lot of
work in North Carolina so it's not a New
York San Francisco but what's like the
average number of people are looking to
save is it hey I need to get to a
million bucks is it ten million dollars
like where are they trying to to get to
we work with a really interesting subset
of clients burger that forty households
managed right around one hundred million
dollars as an office but for the average
person they need to have 1.2 million
dollars in retirement that's gonna spit
off $50,000 a year of top-line income
couple that with Social Security which
we can of course get into see if that's
gonna work out long term I do is the
short answer
the couple that with any pension Social
Security should be alright got it and so
as you're sitting down with these folks
maybe let's go through kind of somebody
walks in the doors a new client
you basically say all right let's start
at the end with the income planning on
the retirement side and then as you walk
backwards what are the things that
you're trying to identify and then how
much of that is more tactical things
versus more of like a mentality around
either saving or investing yeah we want
to really do all of that
practical planning all of this you know
let's get out of these financial plans
let's run the numbers to see if we can't
break the financial plan down behind the
scenes we don't want to do that with
clients we think our interaction with
clients is 90% behavioral focused we
won't understand your relationship with
risk you know there's two ways to think
about it
clients will call us or coming off the
street and the first thing they want to
talk about you know what's this hot
stock tip what are they talking about on
the radio that's going to give me you
know double my investment portfolio in
six weeks generally that's because
they've done a poor job planning they
didn't save enough money now they didn't
feel like they need to take a lot of
risks to get to their number to be able
to retire the flip side of that is we
have some wealthy clients who don't want
to take any risk they feel like they
achieve their number their goal for
retirement and now they want to lock it
under their mattress and you know hope
that the interest old pay for their
retirement
yeah but basically it's the difference
between somebody who wants to get rich
quick and somebody who's comfortable
getting rich slow and disciplined right
and it's one way to think about risk is
can I afford to take it can I afford to
take this much risk and so like like
explain that more so we were talking
earlier a lot of people their mentality
growing up you think about our our
parents our grandparents who they were
waiting in line for gas and bread and
they weren't able to to get the things
that they needed to go to work and live
their lives they have a really different
relationship with money where it's more
of the scarcity mindset oftentimes
people were able to get jobs and they
were younger they have all these
advantages from their parents saving all
this money they were able to take a
little more risk so now the relationship
with money is hey I have enough money in
my bank you can't have to pay all my
bills for the next year my main focus
might be to keep saving but what are you
giving up what opportunity are you
missing out on by just having somebody
sit in your wallets in your checking
account yeah this is one thing that we
talked about a bunch where if you think
about it from a business perspective
right if I have a profitable business
and let's say that my business is
generating a million dollars in cash
flow each year and I just simply keep
taking that million
and just putting it to the side saving
in a bank account one obviously
inflation is eating away at it but but
to is that's a strategy of saving but if
you took that same million dollars of
cash flow and you had some way to
reinvest those profits and you could
turn that million dollars into two
million three million four million
dollars it would pay quite literally to
continue to reinvest your profits into
your business but in order to do that
and have the confidence to do that you
really got to have a pretty good handle
on your business and understand the
machine that you're building in terms of
your return on invested capital you're
exactly right and that's really what we
see our role as if you owned a
successful business you're gonna have a
CFO that you trust who's the CFO for
your business we're the CFO for your
household and just trying to bring that
down to something that people might
understand and that we've been talking
to clients a lot recently about is
interest rates are extremely low let's
talk about your mortgage for a minute if
you want to go buy a million dollar
house you're gonna put just as an
example $200,000 down and the bank is
gonna lend you $800,000 at three and a
half four percent right now I mean it's
unheard of the level of interest rate if
you leave that money your savings again
you're making - now if you're
comfortable investing that money not
putting a hundred percent down on your
home what's the Delta that you can make
if you're borrowing money just the same
way you put it before at three and a
half percent from the bank and your
investments are kicking off a eight
percent return you're making you know
five and a half percent four and a half
percent on every dollar that you didn't
put down to the bank yeah you just gotta
leverage someone else's money yeah and
so how does the mentality and kind of
risk profile change with let's say age
first right so if I'm a young 25 year
old who's just starting their career I
probably don't have as much wealth or
assets and I'm assuming the risk profile
is much much higher versus somebody
who's in their mid to late 50s
who's got quite a bit of wealth and is
nearing the end of their career is that
accurate or do you find the opposite
yeah it is exactly true what you're
saying and it's not always for good
reason you know we grew up in this
Instagram culture where people
see all this wealth and all this wealth
is flaunted everyone drives a nice car
but what you don't realize is that
they're leasing it thinking about some
of our wealthiest clients they drive
cars that they bought 11 years ago they
never made a car payment in their entire
life
but also they're taking a plane that
they own whenever they're going on
vacation with their families they're not
posting that online no one's seen that
versus the 25 year old client who's
driving the Maserati to his humongous
house who everyone knows about yeah well
it's also a lot of that stuff is fake
Ray's rented cars it's rented homes it's
all this stuff too it's really just like
flex on people whereas I think that the
difference is you're you ever seen these
memes online that are like the goals to
be rich not to look rich and right right
which i think is is exactly you're
talking about there and so let's get a
little bit into you know from an
individual's perspective how do you guys
think about portfolio construction and
really talking about traditional assets
outside of cryptic like what is that
conversation like with the various types
of clients you guys have so we're
putting together any investment
recommendations we have the ability to
go out and look at every investment
vehicle Under the Sun we want to screen
it through our own process to identify
now is this will just use public
equities for an example is this stock
set to outperform for the next you know
12 to 18 months one thing that we do
that's slightly different is we
outsource a lot of that value investing
style that people used to love has not
fared well last decade or so this Warren
Buffett type of investing we use a
couple of different research providers
to do that book value and identify which
stocks are set to grow over the next
year and we want to overlay that with
technical analysis to see hey is this
going to be backed by some tailwind is
there momentum that's on our side for
this asset to rise and to rise quickly
what's double here this investment you
guys have never evaluated the strangest
story we had was think is 2017 we
invested in Weight Watchers and it was
over the last 20 years that fortress has
been around the largest single stock
holding in any portfolio and what
happened the reason it became the
largest single holding is because it
more than quadrupled in value before we
sold it and we certainly did not time it
at the very top I mean it would have
been you know eight bagger I think at
one point and we got out between four
and six but it made for a great year
everyone had Weight Watchers memberships
paid for their cell life I think well
what is the when we look at these
investments what do you guys do around
alternative investing right so not
stocks and bonds kind of your
traditional assets but a bit of the
whole private private equity venture
capital meetings we put real estate in
there etc like how do you guys deal with
that so I hate that I'm gonna tee you up
perfectly this is exactly what you want
to hear but it is the truth and you guys
word it a little differently I do want
to call you out about that we're looking
at alts as an asset class which I don't
think they should be described as that
but regardless we want non-correlated
market assets so we are going to buy the
sp500 which we're not doing as a general
rule of thumb we want to be able to
balance that out with something that's
uncorrelated so our goal with all of our
clients who generally have made all of
their wealth or made a significant
matter wealth already is to keep them
rich forever we're not going to make
them rich overnight by any means but if
we can avoid this permanent impairment
of capital by bringing the volatility of
their portfolios down by keeping them
invested for the long run by lowering
their market risk you know we're doing
our job
how does Bitcoin play into that really
the the compliance nightmare question of
the century is how do you answer clients
questions when they are online listening
to you as soon as CNBC talked about this
day and day out and they're looking at
it more often than not unfortunately
hey I saw this thing go from a hundred
dollars a few years ago to fifteen
thousand dollars and if I put in X
amount I'd have you know 50x that amount
now and have you recently sort of
recording this in the end of 2019 the
asset was as high as twenty thousand at
the end of seventeen drew eighty-five
percent down around three thousand
dollars and it's now sitting call it
somewhere in the low 7,000 do you see
interest kind of follow price so in 2017
price goes up a lot a bunch of people
come in asking about it price goes down
a lot in 2018 and everyone kind of goes
away as price recovers in nineteen
people come back and start asking again
or was it a pretty persistent kind of
interest level throughout all those
price movements no way people are
short-term biased they're generally
pessimistic and and really one of the
huge investment risks that's our job to
help people avoid as people get anchored
in their own history biased so they
heard about Bitcoin for the first time
what was two years ago now when it was
at the absolute peak they bought it at
Thanksgiving Christmas when they're you
nieces and nephews are telling them that
if someone was screaming about it on
Twitter they threw in five or ten
thousand dollars something that they
thought they could afford to lose sold
it at the absolute bottom and now
they're kicking themselves ever since
yeah that's when people get the most
upset everyone wants to buy low sell
high really you know it makes for a
great coaster or sang on a mug or a
t-shirt but in practice it's a lot more
difficult and so those people today
where do you think their interest lies
or they hey I bought the top and I sold
it somewhere on the way down I lost
money I don't ever want to talk about a
thing again are they interested in it
from a pure speculation standpoint do
they maybe they've done more work and
now they look at it from as a technology
in an alternative form of currency like
where do they kind of fall on that
spectrum in general people hate being
wrong and that makes for the worse
investment strategy ever so they want to
be pessimistic they want to see this
thing go to zero because think about in
their head they bought at 20,000 let's
say they sold at 8,000 so they lost you
know a little more than half their
investment but hey if it goes a zero is
still not the most wrong out there yeah
basically I'm gonna smartest of the dumb
people right
and that's unfortunately how people
generally invest yeah
and so uh you guys and again we should
caveat like a hundred times throughout
this this is not financial advice this
is just pure Chris's opinion my opinion
in kind of a conversation around
philosophy but not investment advice how
do you think about Bitcoin as a
non-correlated assets or asymmetric
asset or is it more of yeah maybe that's
true but it's just a speculative thing
for right now and so it's okay for
people that want to get some exposure
but keep it really small and capped I
think people that are a lot smarter than
us understand history and are able to
identify over long periods of time that
there have been these new technological
revolutions and those have all been the
keys to creating huge outside wealth you
know things that are gonna last through
generations and if this is the next one
I certainly don't want to be on the
sidelines if this is going to be what
are people calling it Internet 2.0 that
this is going to power your the future
of 5g or whatever everything is based
off of how could you not participate it
so admittedly in full disclosure I do
own some of it it's not enough that's
going to you make a huge difference in
my portfolio in the near term but hey if
you and these other loud guys on Twitter
or right I'll be cheered all the way
how's the macro economy playing to this
what do you think's going on there
this is probably what really plays to
client conversations so our average
client let's say is forty five years old
they are a doctor executive have a two
million dollar portfolio with us own a
successful business that'll be a huge
asset you know as part of their funding
your plan in the future and their
biggest concerns are generally around
geopolitical events now people really
oversell to themselves the importance of
these geopolitical events in the near
term or actually say in the long term
whoever lives in the White House this
year generally is not going to have the
effect you think on your retirement plan
forty years from that when you retire or
when you're thinking you could
potentially run out of money on the flip
side when you see these countries like
Venezuela who have hyperinflation or a
complete corrupt you see them going into
the banks are just taking the money out
this is something to actually be
concerned about now I'm not saying that
will ever happen the United States but
we do want to have international
exposure to stocks and client portfolios
and this geopolitical risk does exist
there's no way to hedge it out
completely there is a really compelling
argument to make with a currency that
isn't backed by a country and so as you
think about that macro economy you
talked earlier about interest rates
being low obviously there's a we call it
non QE or just QE happening do we see
this stock market rally continue forever
like what where are we in these cycles
and are you guys more of the thought
that were closer to the end in the
beginning or do you think that it
doesn't really matter what happens you
guys try to be prepared throughout any
sort of macro environment yeah we want
to build out just like I'm sure everyone
does you know this all-weather portfolio
that that's going to help people feel
comfortable and the reality is there no
one knows when the rally is going to end
and to guess what the sp500 is going to
be next year and when it's gonna peak is
a fool's errand we need to identify what
level of risk you're comfortable taking
well in advance of that so that the next
correction the next recession whatever
it ends up being and whenever it ends up
happening is only you know a blip on the
radar
you know generally these things the bull
market lasts seven to ten years that's
two three years of you know contraction
market cycles exist there's no denying
it
the key is to identify your risk
tolerance beforehand it's extremely
difficult mentally to go through that
exercise we talk too much about what's
going to happen and not enough about how
we're going to react to it
that's whether people make mistakes we
see people that were invested up and
through the financial crisis in 2008
2009 they got out of the market they saw
just enough to where they felt
comfortable they never got back in and
again they feel like geniuses but when
you go back you see that you miss an
incredible unheard-of rally and they are
the ones that are cheering for the next
crash our clients that are younger that
25 to 35 even older than that they have
really nothing to worry about
they have such a long time horizon in
front of them and again people talk
about you know the quote unquote
retirement age being in your early 60s
you still need to have money
indefinitely you don't need to stop
making money as soon as you retire well
and I think that what we're seeing
across just personal finance in general
is this like assault by technologists
where they're trying to build technology
to automate away a lot of financial
advisors roles banks roles other kind of
financial service organizations etc how
do you guys see probably especially with
the younger generation of clients they
roll for those thin tech platforms
versus what people would consider more
traditional advice and and kind of help
that you guys can provide yeah we're
very bullish on how technology can help
us service clients we want clients to be
able to feel comfortable by logging in
seeing where their investments are all
the time generally our clients didn't
grow up using the computers every day
the way we did remembering these logins
these passwords the different data
that's important for privacy protection
is going to create a lot of friction for
them and when they can't log in all of a
sudden their worst fear has been met and
the money's gone reality if you click
forgot password you'll be logged in in
15 minutes yeah I I always wonder if
there's clients who literally just have
cash positions because
so scared of what what's going on in all
the products you're absolutely right and
we love cash viewed as an asset class it
is an investment I remember a story mark
told about what was like a nine figure
client at all his money in one bank that
I couldn't even pick out on a map you
know these are trips 250,000 that's not
really helpful when you have 100 million
dollars yeah
they coin new global currency or are you
you not there yet certainly not there
yet
no why not there are we were in New York
all last week together I think we walked
by two places that accepted Bitcoin we
walked past every place that except my
American Express card
I'll give the American Express points
the nod on global currency at the moment
before Bitcoin that's fair in the United
States true right I saw I take your word
for it I saw a stat from a coin metrics
Nick Carter than those guys that last
year in 2018 bitcoins adjusted on change
transaction volume so this is not
exchange traded volume and this is
adjusted for things like mixers or
exchanges etc rights it's doing its best
job to figure out what is actual
economic activity that's on chain was
750 plus billion dollars in 2018 and so
if you compare that to venmo PayPal or
Apple pay bitcoins on chain transaction
volume Dwarfs those three and these are
people that are spending it on goods and
services you're saying that's how
they're so that's part of the challenge
is what exactly are they spending it on
right we don't know but are they sending
it you know me sending you money am i
send spending it somewhere to actually
buy a good or a service could I be
moving it between two of my own accounts
it's really hard to tell what the
purpose is but just the fact that 750
billion dollars of transaction volume on
chain in some adjusted manner
you know seven hundred billion dollars
pretty big number you know it's really
interesting I got an email last week
what was that huge exchange that closed
down so this is back to your point about
you know there's so many of these Robo
advisors that are going to disrupt the
industry of you know financial services
and and I don't see it that way at all
no one wants to call 1-800 number ever
again when you need someone you want to
call someone that's going to pick up the
phone what's it like when you're trying
to call coinbase to make sure that your
transaction with no phone number but
that's concerning but what you're
basically getting at is this idea that
as automation becomes more prolific and
machines and algorithms start to get rid
of the more mundane aspects of jobs and
the less creative aspects of jobs
it actually makes advice and the
creative components more valuable right
so so it's a thing where the machines
are really good at doing kind of work
that is repetitive or somewhat mundane
and they're really good at like
computations etc but in terms of the
actual creativity human ingenuity right
and and the advice component machines
are still pretty bad at that compared to
to the best humans it's I think that
that makes that advice much more
valuable over time and it goes back to
the who do you trust and people are so
concerned with even their identity is
safe and and well deserved concerned
over you know don't want to put your
social security number in there but I
guess I've kind of have a maybe a
pessimistic view on this I think if
someone wants my information bad enough
they're probably gonna get it no matter
what I do if I don't save my password so
opt me into automating everything you
know I want every bill pay I don't want
to think about any of that yeah I mean
look if you go in the black market I can
definitely buy your stuff you can have
it for free right then I made 10 bucks
for sure
and so what about like custody and other
aspects of bitcoins it's not just the
asset itself but let's say a client
walks in and says hey I want Bitcoin in
my portfolio how do you guys think about
the options to get exposure for that
client
and what are some of the risks or
obstacles there that probably still
exist today but definitely existed two
years ago yeah we can't wait to see some
of these big custodians like fidelity
add this on to you know the RA chassis
so we can have the option for exposure
to it there was a really you know for a
moment and this was over a year ago we
had clients calling in asking for that
motion PTC yeah that Bitcoin trust when
you look at it it's trading or it was
trading what 34 cent premium so it's hey
you're real worried about the fees now
you're paying a 30 percent premium on
this asset okay well like where exactly
do you think it's going how are you you
know everything else you're talking
about you sound like a value investor
but now you're paying 30 percent premium
really doing against the grand your
investment policy here yeah and so is it
custody is the big obstacle once and we
decides they want it or there are other
things custody and compliance are
generally the big obstacles with all
this and this is why I don't think the
adoption is where ever would like it to
be yet you're asking people who have
grown up in a completely different age
to adopt a new technology that I don't
understand completely yet I don't know
if you understand it completely yet but
they don't understand it you know at an
elementary level and now you want
lawmakers to make it comfortable for a
trillion-dollar asset change from you
know the generation before us to us to
say hey we want to put what what are you
trying to 1% that's still a lot of
dollars and there's a lot of risks you
know congressmen and Senators everywhere
maybe but if you look I think at the
Fiat system there's more money
laundering that goes on in the Fiat
system there's way more risk I think in
the fractional reserve system as you see
with things like the global financial
crisis etc versus a bearer asset that is
not participating a fractional reserve
what do they say about those pioneers
what they get slaughtered yeah I want to
bet on the people with all the money so
as much as disrupting
central bankers maybe you know what's
needed to adopt and grow in advance as a
society around finances I don't know if
I want to bet against the guy who's
controlling interest rates yeah well
here's the one of the things that I can
spend a lot of time on is so the
creation of double entry accounting
happened in the early medieval times of
the Middle East is where most people
think it happened probably somewhere in
like 70 to 100 AD and then eventually
made its way to Europe and was
popularized by two separate folks one
was a merchant who started using it I
think it's around like 1300 ad and then
eventually one of the Medici family
members started using at the Medici bank
and that's really kind of where it
became super popular and now obviously
the entire global financial system is
built on double entry accounting but
that one single invention created a
massive inflection point in human
history and so if you think about there
was single entry accounting then we got
double entry counting massive inflection
point I'd argue that triple entry
accounting which is what a block chain
or Bitcoin as an application provides
could be an even larger inflection point
in human history
simply because that triple entry
accounting system is now going to
permeate the globe because it's being
built on the back of the internet yeah
you can innovate and you can you know we
certainly believe that innovation is
happening more rapidly than ever this is
hyperbolic innovation that you're
describing if you're not on the front
end of that you're you're gonna miss out
yeah what what's the biggest mistakes
you see especially younger clients make
so let's call it sub 40 years old what
are the big mistakes they make so I'm
going to talk about size of my mouth a
little bit here because it applies to
different people generally the issue for
the masses is people are not saving any
money they're not putting any money away
for a rainy day
and eventually they're they're gonna
need it and they're not going to have it
I think it's what is it less than half
people could come up with like a four
hundred dollar bill
yeah it's less than or more than I think
it's just 50% of Americans can't come up
with four hundred dollars for an
emergency bill yes terrifying and when
you look at it from you asked about
younger people but let me jump to the
older people right now 1.2 million
dollars to retire is a pipe dream to
miss people I think the average for when
Kay balance is under $40,000 if you were
going to spend that in a year - yeah so
what are those people do just keep
working sad sad reality there's a
there's only a few levers that you can
pull can either which are keep working
save more money make more money you know
change your your investment strategy
again and essentially a lever to make
more money or use less and it's a pretty
morbid thought process and is it a thing
where the earlier you start it's just
compounding and timer on your side and
so yeah having better strategies etc
helps but but it is just a thing of
starting early gives you a massive
advantage oh my goodness humans are not
that smart and this is the easiest
example on on how to figure that out
under appreciating the power of
compounding is the biggest mistake that
anyone can make and the easiest way to
put it
read this Bill Gates quote while back
you know you can ask anyone like two
times two is four you know 10 times 10
is 100 but ask them what 17 times 21 is
that's the limit of our minds computing
power I don't I don't know anyone that
could do that without grabbing my first
thought be to grab my calculator to you
but that's when you're talking about
this power of compounding and when you
can apply that to your money that you
crack the code it becomes rather simple
and the idea that people don't make
enough money to save is is just
fundamentally incorrect we were talking
to hundreds of people a week most of
them making you know less money than
your average clients now and they
still had successful retirements but you
can't overspend you can't live beyond
your means it's not rocket science it's
just not what people want to hear yeah
it's basically look whatever you make
you got to spend less right you can be
disappointed kind of executing an
intelligent plan and then you need to
leverage compounding in time right yeah
no it's a like if I can figure it out
anybody can figure it out it's based on
percentages so there's been huge massive
studies done and you need to be saving
10 to 15% of your your income per year
and this is if you're starting like 25
so that's that's the true where does
that get you so so let's say that you
make $40,000 a year basically if you
could say four grand a year that puts
you on track and you do that year in
year out since you were younger where
does that put you yeah you'll be at
eight hundred thousand to two million
dollars assuming you have a realistic
long-term annualized rate of return
which is easier said than done
there's going to be some draw downs
you're gonna need to stay invested
you're gonna be big dollar amounts later
on in life but that's going to be able
to kick off the annualized salad that
you're used to receiving in retirement
because things things do slow down
generally people spend about 80% of
their take or their current spending in
retirement think things naturally go
down here you're spending you're not
traveling to work you're not buying your
clothes for work every few months
there's just less wear and tear on
everything Amy you gotta have a fly
outfit go play bingo if everyone
switches to black t-shirts that that'll
save them some money
listen it's uh it's like a uniform man
what uh what about taxes and we were
talking earlier about a whole bunch of
different tax strategies and stuff like
how important is it to take into account
taxes and you hear rich people all the
time doing all kinds of crazy things to
either perception standpoint or in
reality lower their tax burden or tax
payments is that one actually helpful to
those rich people and then to kind of
everyday people you know is it helpful
to folks like us who want to you know
they read about this stuff but they
don't actually know like should I be
worried about taxes or is it just
you know kind of the the MTV version of
the world if you want to see someone
lose their mind or if you want to fill a
room with people tell them that you're
going to save the money on taxes it's
the best you know financial marketing of
all time this is how you avoid taxes let
me go on the record
you can't just avoid it without breaking
the law they're there for a reason and
when you go back and think about it it
there they're not all that bad and
historically and the reason I'm saying
this is when you look at the last you
know 40 50 60 years
historically we're at an extremely low
tax rate environment so what exactly
where do you want the balance to be you
know no one wants potholes in the road
everyone wants to go to good schools but
no one wants to pay any taxes just like
hey let's just level set a little bit
what what does everyone think is fair
it's higher roughly what you're paying
so what do you think about like the
wealth tax skirt school want to know who
has the best URL crypto calm that's
right
crypto calm they're crypto platform with
one goal mother mass adoption that's why
we're all here we're trying to get
crypto in every wallet crypto calm is
helping people do that through buying
earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto calm
go help your boy out tell them pomp
sense you download the app or visit
crypto comm pumps got you always
everyone to get into mining and didn't
know how don't worry your boy pops
gotcha everybody got some electricity
and Wi-Fi all you got to do is go to
coin mine comm you buy a coin mine it's
like an Xbox or a Playstation that helps
you turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right you purchase it it shows up
at your doorstep you pull it out of the
box you plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi
five minutes or less you're mining
Bitcoin all you have to do is control it
from the mobile app they provide and
then you receive over-the-air updates
that add new coins and new features on a
consistent basis kind of like how Tesla
does over-the-air updates and updates
the car software just your update your
coin mine consumer mining made easy
that's right go to coin mine com
tell them pump Sencha and thank me later
one more word from our sponsor block bye
new interest account allows you to
securely deposit your Bitcoin or
Ethernet block by and receive 6% annual
interest paid monthly and cryptocurrency
this rate actually compound so you
receive a 6.2 percent APY which is very
attractive given the alternatives so you
can actually take your Bitcoin you can
deposit it with block Phi and get paid
an interest rate of 6% in return go
check out block 5 comm / pump again
block 5 comm / pump to sign up and start
earning interest on your crypto today I
think I asked about the wealth tax I
think it's really interesting that in
this is just in the last week who was it
Bezos gave away a ton of money and PBS
Weyland 95 million dollars and the that
didn't give a viral what did go viral
was the guy who responded said just pay
taxes which hey you know these loopholes
do exist on these corporate taxes and
you can see that Amazon and they're
certainly not the first ones do it their
effective corporate tax rate was zero
percent last year and that does seem
crazy to me
but you're creating this environment
that incentivizes them to move their
money to inform countries with true me
low tax rates and keep the money over
there and not bring it back so it's more
complicated than people think so I would
argue that by introducing things like
the wealth tax what you're essentially
doing is you're transferring capital
from the best capital allocators in the
world which tend to be you know
successful business owners large wealthy
families or individuals and the reason
whether the best capital allocators is
that's how they've built those big
businesses or wealth etc and you're
transferring that from the best capital
allocators to notoriously the worst
which is governments yeah i can agree
with that i it would be crazy if that
the way you incentivized our government
was by sticking to a budget and they had
to stick to the budget to keep their job
to keep their benefits you know how we
quickly with things change i think that
it would be
for there to be some sort of like
process where the government officials
have to present their capital allocation
strategy every one or two years to a
Council of the most successful business
owners in America I love it
well who wasn't what was the it was like
the Roman Empire or you didn't run for
office they forced you to do it that's
how I think it should happen if you're
running to be for office or for
president I'm not gonna lie that job
doesn't seem fun at all people are just
mad at you no matter what you decide
half of the country's gonna think you
know you're the worst person of all time
who would run for that job that is
insane to me we should start putting
names in a hat and just forcing someone
to be elected who would you force I
don't know I I kind of root for chaos in
situations like this so let's send you
up there for like six monsters
we don't need me today that stuff that
would be a nightmare for me and for
everybody else I got three picks for you
but you go first you pick a person I'll
name a person that you would force to be
President because you think that they
would do a good job specifically with a
bent towards the economy so one thing we
should talk about next is and this is to
your point about we should be able to
see how these politicians spend their
money I want to see how someone invests
and spends their money before I'm
willing to throw them up there and I
want full transparency none of this took
me you know five years to release my tax
records I need to see them you know
right now on the spot without you doing
anything to them and then we'll send you
up there to run the nation's economy
I would pick Bezos as one I would pick
Elon Musk as two and I'll tell you why
in a second and the third person I would
pick some shady towny going on over
there
my third pick would be somebody who
who has the intersection of economics
math and Becca Jim Simons
right who basically just understands how
to use data and math to drive economic
return now I'll tell you here the answer
is who who's running rentec right now so
our people don't know this is a massive
hedge fund you can't get in with less
than hundred million dollars so even if
you have more than that I still don't
think they'll let you in they cap the
amount of money that they will work with
every year and they're averaging what
meta fees which their fees are
ridiculous forty and four I think is
what they're for and 42 they're paying
and averaging 40 percent annualized
returns after fees Jim Simons is
Renaissance yeah we'll fix Social
Security real quick
the reason why I would pick elan for one
of it is I believe that the way to get
out of America's dead is innovation and
to return back to entrepreneurship and
innovation and embrace taking these wild
bets like the Industrial Revolution the
space race etc and it's not so much that
he so he or somebody like him would
figure it out but if you look at
somebody like I think it says the
president or CEO of SpaceX is this woman
I think her name's Carolyn Shotwell but
she would be a great person you just
wanted to see if she can find aliens not
weird you know the aliens exist but no
but if you think about right like really
large budgets super super innovative and
if successful drives such an economic
boom for a country that you get out of
this hole we're just holding on we're
trying to plug the holes like you know
the ships sinking we're under debt let's
raise the debt ceiling that type of
stuff and instead what it does is if it
goes back into a super offensive mindset
we're being a good capital allocator
driving innovation and
ultimately trying to spur economic
growth through what is similar to a
private business if you take that
approach pretty much every politician
would fail that test you know I love
that answer I just think that the team
over at rentec can do that more
effectively than an Elan and company
maybe all right
what is the one biggest surprise that
you've had a client walk in and tell you
the biggest surprise I ever have been
talking to new clients is that I want
like what like what's the craziest story
a client said it walked in and said hey
I gotta tell you and then told you X and
you were like wait run that back what
did you just say that was the craziest
thing I've Christ ever told you don't
don't tell me somebody admitted to
murdering anybody but it was the
craziest thing a client's told you I had
a prospective client let's let's decide
exactly which stories we can share here
before we throw them on air it's
interesting clients call us very early
on in a lot of pivotal life decisions
when you think about the most taboo
conversations you can have we're
recording this a few days before
Thanksgiving the things you don't want
to talk about in front of your
grandparents are you know health
concerns relationship marital concerns
and finances are generally up there with
things that people don't want to share
publicly we work with families at the
intersection of all three of those
things so we know the dynamics of their
families a lot of the times we know a
lot of health concerns that we can't
talk about or that we want to help you
know avoid offset or address in some
different way and then obviously we are
managing their entire financial lives
more often than not and to have those
three things intersect
you know it's hey Chris I don't know if
you're doing today I need you to get on
a plane and come meet me and my lawyer
come to this you know doctor with me
things are about to change
you need to be at the epicenter of it
before I finish I always ask rapid-fire
questions
this wasn't rapid-fire what do you think
is the most important company in crypto
right now I don't know if you're gonna
like this answer I think coinbase when
you are looking at trying to adopt
something the user experience I think is
well undervalued those guys do a great
job of making it really easy to to use
what regulation would you change or
improve if you could in the crypto space
anywhere it's just in finance in general
we need to absolutely eliminate this
accredited investor limits if
something's a good investment people
should be able to do it trust that
people will educate themselves when it
comes to their money they have
everything to gain and what would you
say is your most controversial thought
in finance the way do you say finance or
finance I say finance finance like a
normal person
okay for all those out there that say
was it finance like what are you guys
doing I think that the craziest thing
people are doing is and in this is
specific to my industry is no one's
asking how we manage our own assets
explain that when you go to hire a
financial advisor if the first question
here not asking is how do you manage
your own finances what are you doing how
would you start the conversation any way
else so are you saying that people
should only go with folks who they agree
with how that person is personally
managing their own capital well would
you go to the gym and hire a trainer if
you is out of shape would you go to your
dentist people general are all messed up
people do that all the time
you shouldn't that be a crazy thing to
do yeah that's fair what's the most
important book you've ever read that's a
great question I read a lot of books you
I go back and read more often than not
just because it's one of those things
where
if you read a book different times
during your life you're gonna get a lot
more out of it I don't know if I can
just settle on just one just one I read
books every throat throwing out the
alchemist that was a pretty wild book
I've uh
so my mom actually had copies of that
sing around our house growing up and all
throughout college she would reread it
every single year which is kind of crazy
but it's something that I picked up and
I think it served me pretty well aliens
let's get to the real part of this
podcast real or not of course they're
real why what's that saying words like
there are more stars in the sky than
grains of sand on every Beach really
yeah just like go back to your math if
you know you're talking about single
entry double entry now you just scale it
up to triple if big math guy I like to
think I am but ma I can't fathom how
expansive the universe is so let's just
say we're the only one seems so naive
have we contacted them or have they
contacted us like do you think there's
been contact I think they'd be here if
they thought were interesting you didn't
answer my question I I'm sure we're
being monitored like some sort of
science experiment probably a petri dish
to someone else you think so
absolutely and maybe it's not us so
you're trying to get over my skis with
math you when you think of the speed of
light the fastest way humans are able to
think about this if you're hundreds of
light-years away and you look back
you're looking back in time now so what
are you seeing
you're not seeing us here right now
you're seeing like dinosaurs man listen
I saw a crazy meme on the internet said
if you think about hair follicles they
disintegrate when they go into the
ground so how do we know that dinosaurs
didn't have like long hair well don't we
do like you have like mullets like
mammoths that that was the I'm gonna try
to find the the photo getting all linked
to it in the in the show notes
that's why one mine thumbnail to be
hairy dinosaur mullets no is like a
dinosaur with a bullet it was like how
do we know they didn't have weird
haircuts alright man now listen we we
talk about aliens a lot but I might have
to start asking people about dinosaurs
too the best question you've ever asked
in this podcast is if aliens exist do
they have pets legitimate question
that's the best question you've ever had
do you think so of course why well think
about all throughout history or I mean
and again so like a piece of a grain of
sand infinitely expansive people have
always had pets yeah that's true what if
the dinosaurs were the aliens pets
alright you get asked a lot a question -
to wrap this up what do you got for me
when's the wedding
Oh May everyone's talked about the
wedding now
miss Polina if you're listening I think
that she has selected a date but when
when the date is official I will let
everyone know and maybe it will you know
not have everyone come to the wedding
but they will throw a little little
party afterwards in New York somewhere
and I'm petitioning to have everyone and
anyone who wants to come to show up
polenta is open to the idea but we have
some more negotiating to go so this is
for for all your Twitter followers I
know they're wondering this because
you've been buying these bitcoins
forever
you're never gonna sell hold it forever
I mean I've never said any of that I
don't give advice in in reality at what
price would you take some off the table
and think about it like this if it could
go to a hundred thousand dollars per
Bitcoin or whatever your price target
that you've addressed publicly is at
what point do you take some risk off the
table honestly my grandkids I have the
Bitcoin that I own alright it's a
beautiful way to look at risk here we go
risk tolerance off the charts but it's
not risk I actually think that it is
mathematically more risky to hold dollar
that it is Bitcoin if you look out over
a 200 year time frame well I'm not
saying hold dollars I didn't say that
but I'm just saying but any asset in the
traditional financial system is dollar
denominated and the reason why I say
that is there's two things that Bitcoin
has one is the separation of state and
money and the second is it's a not it's
a it's a new currency and so if you look
at it mathematically what is the average
life cycle or lifetime of a currency
we're getting pretty deep into the
lifetime of the US dollar and then so
just mathematically it's unlikely that
it will last for another 200 years let's
say Bitcoin has a higher probability of
lasting for 200 years than something
like a dollar and the second thing is I
believe that 200 years from now we will
look back and people will say wait there
used to be money that was controlled and
governed and created by the state that's
weird I think that the separation of
state and money is a foregone conclusion
at this point because of things like
triple entry accounting the transparency
of a blockchain etc and so while that
seems radical today 200 years from now
it's gonna be no brainer 200 years from
now they're gonna take this audio
they're gonna have put it through six
different new technologies and looking
about who's this crazy guy who is 200
years ago talking about the separation
of state money so on the record
you'll never diversify your investment
portfolio I had a friend one time who
told me the best way to diversify is to
make more money okay and if you think
about that right it's a it's taking a
very long term low time preference
passive approach to any investment
that's not just Bitcoin it's you know I
know a lot of people who would
dollar-cost average into the SP for
example and it's not like they have in
their head hey at some point I'm gonna
take money out of the SP it's this is
where I'm going to store a portion of my
wealth for the rest of my life and I'm
going to continue to dollar-cost average
into that position and over time that
position will continue to grow and so if
you look at your investments or assets
that way
it's less about like the short term
investing and where's the price today
etc and it's much more decision around
asset allocation and then as you make
money you basically allocate based on
that asset allocation and if you have a
really really long time preference as
the study of fidelity showed the people
who may had the best returning accounts
or the people who died or forgot their
password and so time is your friend so
the way you're getting out of this is
saying you will for future dollars
you won't allocate 110 percent of it
into Bitcoin you'll eventually allocate
a portion of it into something else yeah
I mean everyone knows that I always show
right here I've been very clear about
the asset allocation that I've had and
nobody ever asks me about what do I do
with the other 50 so percent or so and
so the joke that I always say is like
it's not like I'm like levered up on you
know like 6x levered hedge fund
strategies or I'm not like buying
lottery tickets it's actually a lot of
cash a little bit of real estate and
like super safe more like barbell
strategy type approach and so if you
look at it as one part of my portfolio
it would be considered very speculative
and risky the other part is super safe
and non risky that blended risk profile
obtains actually not that bad
given my age and kind of my risk
tolerance there's a lot of people though
who want the exact opposite direction
they put it you know 80 90 percent of
their wealth into these speculative
assets and they didn't have kind of an
asset allocation strategy they're
they're super over-rotated on on this
stuff and so when the price drops 85
percent they lose material parts of
their net worth right and so I think
that it's why I say it all the time on
Twitter etc is just you know that
there's some very basic rules here
around don't invest more money than
you're willing to lose right you know or
that you can that you can actually
withstand losing and things like that
that are just tried and true in every
investment in the world
they still apply here even though this
is new we'll have to do that for the
next one we'll go through your asset
allocation
I got some weird stuff in there oh I'm a
lawyer what what's the weirdest thing
you have in your portfolio I don't think
it is anything that's weird
Bitcoin people people would say is weird
I iron more bonds than a lot of
allocators you know would allow me to
and it's still an extremely small
percentage have a blueberry farm in
there people think that's weird
I know about the blueberry farm oh yeah
the craziest thing I have is I have
exposure to a company called neck tome
which provides I'm gonna paraphrase very
broadly but they provide an oxygenated
process that delivers cryogenic freezing
like technology and what it does is it
basically preserves the structure of
your brain and so that they can with
almost a hundred percent structural
integrity preserve your brain at the
time of death and they could do
everything from research to eventually
they would like to be able to take your
brain and because they preserve the
synaptic connections etc where knowledge
and experience and and information is
stored into a computer you for degree
that deal I for anyone listening past
but tell them your most on brand
investment this isn't my favorite thing
you've ever invested in which one come
on you give them a shout out like every
week
your favorite restaurant Oh McDonald's
what up yeah actually somebody while
we're sitting here texted me and
literally with a selfie and they're at
McDonald's and said thinking of you and
so it's the best restaurant America
period hands down no question it's you
know exactly what you're gonna get it
always says taste the same it's cheap
services fast you can find on every
street corner they have Wi-Fi now and my
favorite part tell me a dirty McDonald's
you've ever gone to pulling if you're
listening this tell me when you want to
get a dinner it's on me
man where can people find you on the
Internet that's my name Chris or CH rsg
you re I think I have you in my Twitter
and Instagram as my burner accounts just
because you told me not to do that so I
had to alright well we'll do this again
in the future thanks so much thank you
hey everyone
pop here if you like this episode of off
the chain and want to help us take
crypto to the top of the Apple Spotify
and other podcast charts please do us a
favor and rate review and subscribe to
review simply go to the off-the-chain
homepage scroll down until you see the
five blank stars taking 15 seconds to
fill those stars in and leave a quick
review goes a long way in helping us
take the entire crypto ecosystem to the
top of the charts I appreciate you
listening and see you next time on off
the chain